here to react to all of this former
deputy assistant to the president
Sebastian Gorka also former senior
intelligence officer current lieutenant
colonel Tony Schaefer former NYPD
counterterrorism lieutenant who actually
surveilled individuals who attended the
mosque in Paterson New Jersey where this
gentleman attended this was in the early
2000s bill Majority is with us let me
start so you at the New York City as a
little tenant you're the New York City
counterterrorism task force right
intelligence intelligence okay how many
years were you with that department
approximately fourteen years okay and as
part of that that the Commissioner at
the time was Ray Kelly if I recall yes
and Ray Kelly said okay we've got to
follow leads wherever they take us about
radicalism so we don't have another 9/11
right that took you to evidence took you
to this mosque where this this guy had
attended at this point right what
happened after 9/11 Sean we didn't know
we didn't know what we had in front of
us in New York City so we started to get
sources and to run investigations and
what we realized was these people that
were in New York City that we knew what
bad people you aren't profiling people
because they're mob salutely not it's
it's this the intelligence game is
simple you develop human Intel they
report back to you and you're able to
figure out who the bad guys are oh yeah
and so you surveilled a specific mom yes
was there radicalism going absolutely
absolutely people from New York led us
to this place into New Jersey and what
we realized that was going on not only
in this mosque in in in Paterson
but in Jersey City all up and down the
east coast there's certain things that
are being said meetings that are taking
place things I can't go into obviously
because there's still what you would
define it as radical Islamic thought
absolutely was it also plotting and
planning radical Islamic terror
absolutely not only thought but hatred
hatred to America hatred to our way of
life the way we think of what we do
absolutely how many people do you think
in the course of this surveillance
program that the NYPD had which I
thought was a smart ideas like stop and
frisk was a smart idea we're saving
lives how many people would you say
individually you knew
radicalized by your surveillance of this
particular mosque from this particular
mosque I would say would have to be at
least over 20 people Wow one mosque in
one mosque and how many in other places
that's not to say they're going to go
out and to do something but they're
talking about that they're talking about
it and their thoughts are not as the
same as our thought process they don't
love our country this country they don't
like the way we are they think it should
be changed if it's 20 in that mosque how
many can you think estimate off the top
of your head in all of your surveillance
you know it would have to be over the
thousand over a thousand over a thousand
yes in the New York metropolitan area
well you have to understand and if I
could just backtrack not only I worked
the whole East Coast because of Ray
Kelly we were put into place to go
outside of New York City wherever there
might wherever chatter of terror and you
would investigate and you found it and
we found it yes and then all of a sudden
DeBlasio becomes mayor ends that
surveillance program and some of the
surveillance programs and handcuffed and
handcuffed but you can't do your job
exactly and when you put and you know
you you put police officers in the
position will give them a lot of
resources or little resources they're
gonna do their job but they've been
basically handcuffed in a place where
it's very difficult to get their job
done dr. korkor let me bring you in so
DeBlasio ends the surveillance program
they had found over a thousand people
they believe a radicalized they're now
free to do whatever they want nobody's
checking into them Schumer authored the
diversity visa program people can come
in no vetting bring 23 more people with
them we know nothing about them this is
spectacularly stupid and dangerous to
the American people yes it's a matter of
life and death Sean and it's not just
about the Blasio it's not just about
Cuomo it's about the Obama
administration I want to remind your
viewers in case they haven't heard it
before in 20 in 2011 under pressure from
care the so called Muslim civil rights
organization that does not represent
Muslims in America the White House bowed
to their pressure and told the FBI this
is an unclassified memo from the White
House they wrote to the then Attorney
General Eric Holder and to the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs the most see
a military officer in the Pentagon and
said from this day forward there are
certain words and phrases that you are
not allowed to use when you are training
our agents and our military and
counterterrorism and that included jihad
that included discussion of Islam so
you're going into battle trying to
understand the enemy and you're not
being allowed to use the words that they
use to describe themselves this is the
insanity of the last eight years Shan
lieutenant colonel Schaffer let me get
your reaction all this look everything
that's been said here tonight the
leadership in New York are aware of the
mayor the governor and surely Chuck
Schumer all the intel lieutenant is
talking about was available to them
they've been briefed on it what makes it
far worse is that these people are not
only negligent they are purposely
setting up as I said this morning a
purposeful push to make us like Europe
to make us as vulnerable lieutenant
talked about these unassimilated
enclaves which are like open pits of
gasoline waiting for a flame you saw the
terrorists finally take that and like
that flame that's what we have to deal
with and I was mortified last night Sean
to hear
Governor Cuomo lie to the people of New
York and to America he knew at that
point in time that this guy was not a
quote/unquote lone wolf but lone wolf
methodology is completely false with his
own wolf Victor absolutely this is a
vector this is a known vector and as
disclosed today look I heard last night
that the NYPD had notes that were
released later you know Sean they knew
last night that this guy was part of a
larger network they are lying to the
American people they're lying constantly
policies and it cannot be continued if
we would we would use common sense
people would be alive today yes that is
you agree with up and down like that you
worried with that dr. korkor because I
agree with that how many cases have we
seen when individual ends up killing
people after months of planning
and the intelligence community the FBI
was warned about them investor precisely
and somebody shot it down
sorry we had to take orders shut it down
alright I have a huge announcement
tonight coming up